Alicia's friend tells me she died here
at the hospital a day after she went
into cardiac arrest earlier this week
those who love her say they're still in
shock a local cardiologist tells me it's
important to always be aware of any risk
she had a contagious smile and made
everybody so happy around her to know
Alicia groblinghoff was to love her she
was an amazing human being a
humanitarian her friend and boss of 30
Years Michelle Morgan shared everything
she'll miss just days after the 46 year
old suddenly died suddenly without
warning collapsed at the gym and
suffered a massive Cardiac Arrest Morgan
says Alicia had no history of heart
issues she's one of several who have
died of cardiac arrest in the last week
here in Las Vegas what we emphasize here
is trying to mitigate risk cardiologist
Dr Alfred danielin says no matter your
age or health it's important to get your
heart checked for things like congenital
defects coronary artery disease
electrical problems or issues related to
covid-19 including myocarditis yes we
did see uh incidents it was a little
higher with the vaccine but again this
was self-limited nobody had long-term
equally from this Morgan says she's
still in shock that this could happen to
someone with so much life ahead of them
we never think
that we're going to leave work on Friday
and not come back on Monday and she
hopes Alicia's story can live on for
everyone who loved her she was a
beautiful human being and this should
not have happened
Michelle says Alicia's family does not
know what caused her Cardiac Arrest at
this time she did start a GoFundMe to
help her family with medical expenses
and funeral expenses we have more
information on our website 8newsnow.com
if you'd like to help reporting live
tonight social Loftus 8 News Now